[Music]
okay
so this is my review of your honor
episode
eight like all your honor episodes it
doesn't have a title
i am going to make a custom title for
this episode and call it the masked
juror
let me just say off the bat this is one
of the strangest episodes of television
i've ever watched
and it's following one of the strangest
decisions i've seen a network make in
showtime to not have an episode
air last week and you can't say it's
because the episode wasn't finished
because
i've had this screener sitting for a
while now so it was ready to go and they
decided to wait a week
to really kill momentum for viewers and
it makes you
have higher expectations now because you
waited an extra week for this episode
so going into it what made it
fascinating
in a sense to watch is watching a
production that
is really now laying into corona times
and now
putting our storyline in the current
pandemic
we get this monologue from michael here
at the trial
of carlo and it comes right before the
title card for the show and he's talking
about how
the press can't come in because of this
pandemic and they're going to do a deep
clean every night
and you see this one courtroom worker
she puts her mask on
but what was really weird was
they decided to have one juror wear a
mask they're not six feet apart
and everyone else just says screw it i
don't know if they were going for that
that was our hint that the smart juror
was wearing the mask
and that she's the one that michael's
gonna have to deal with later and get
rid of
but it was such a weird decision because
if you're gonna have
one of the jurors wear a mask why not
have all of them wear a mask in the jury
or none of them it was really really
strange and
what's frustrating about showtime is
it's owned by cbs i have a lot of issues
a lot of cbs
programming a lot of stuff they put on
cbs all access there's a stink that cbs
has and
i feel like that stink is on this series
now and we're getting a lot of stuff you
just roll your eyes at and
having this one juror where the mask and
the rest not was one of them
now what's so impressive about this
episode is it's really hard to pull off
on tv
a really boring trial episode they're
usually at least
decently entertaining and somehow this
was really
really boring and you really start to
feel that settle in when this defense
attorney is going on this long monologue
about carlos cell being like his home
and that kofi was this invader what
makes it so
boring and the feeling while you're
watching the show where you're zoning
out is because
you've lost sympathy for michael at this
point he's not a likable character
and he is our main character and so you
can't really root for him anymore
and to compare it which actually works
here not just conveniently because he
played walter white but if you compare
to breaking bad
the more and more walter white came out
of our good graces
the more you had someone to root for in
a jesse and
if adam was more likable of a character
i think they could pull that off and
then we could still kind of root for
adam but
adam is even more hateable than michael
so you have no one you're actually
attaching to and know where you can kind
of
sit in and if you're not going to have
someone you can
connect to as an audience member you
need to have the stakes really high and
be on the edge of your seat which was
kind of happening in the middle of the
season but
like my concern was that once jimmy
found out
michael was the one behind everything
that the show might have peaked there
because now we're running into the issue
now it's like just watching michael
survive at this point and it's not
that interesting because there's no
looming mystery here either during this
trial we know everything we know exactly
what's going on
so you're kind of just watching things
play out and wonder if this character
you don't like
is going to survive another day which
does not make for compelling drama and
what also doesn't help is they're
really giving you predictable outcomes
meaning you see nancy costello
clearly now the past couple episodes
they've set her up is to be the one
who's going to figure out what's really
going on
they really push that down our throats
this episode again like okay we
get it like you're just making the
reveals later on not gonna have payoff
like
we know now yeah nancy castello's had
like six scenes where she's
caught on to the corruption going on
obviously she's gonna be the one that
figures this out now it's not all bad
here i mean
i'm really impressed by the acting in
this show i actually thought
maura tierney who plays the prosecuting
attorney here
was excellent i thought everyone really
held their weight here acting wise but
it's bogged down by
a really boring script and mostly what
this episode really was was just
us watching michael survive another day
as a judge
and his obstacle this episode was the
mass juror who
is someone who clearly wants
carlo to go down and she's the one with
the note about self defense not being a
thing in prison so
michael takes care of that eventually by
getting into her phone
and putting the search term kofi jones
which he said no one to do so he will
throw her out to kind of
settle down jimmy who's given him a
deadline now now let's just go
into our daily bashing of the character
of adam this is nothing to do i see
people
complaining saying the actor's bad i do
not think the act is bad i think hunter
dewan's actually a really good actor
here
i just think he's given a poor character
and i feel bad for him and
because when an actor gets really his
first
starring role and it's a character
that's not likeable and just
written poorly it can actually reflect
on the actor but here i don't see that i
think he's actually really good
but adam's story my god this episode so
we got this love triangle they got going
with frannie who's been gone for like
six episodes she's back
and i forgot what she's even about at
this point but
all i know is they reaffirm that she
likes her underage
high school boys like adam and she can't
wait till he's 18
and then they could be out about
everything again i don't understand why
they casted an actress that does not
look old enough here
to really reiterate in our minds
subconsciously what's
actually wrong with this situation she
looks like she's adam's h total miscast
and what's so funny to me about adam and
how frustrating he is is
when i do relate to michael and wish he
would do more to adam because
adam gets into nyu this thing he's set
up this is like his dream
but he conveniently remembers this quote
his mom said to him
go deep not wide so i guess he takes go
deep as
going deep into fia baxter here and
not doing his dream of nyu and staying
around
for the sister of the boy he killed
complete psychopath and this is why he's
completely unlikable and you have no
sympathy for him and when michael takes
him out to celebrate this
news and adam says he doesn't want to go
and wants to have a gap year
i would have flipped the table if i was
michael that point i actually wanted him
to snap it at him like you gotta be
kidding me
again michael is busting his ass this
whole
show to protect adam and adam does not
care
he's just being reckless and they try to
make us feel for adam in the scenes when
he's talking to fia about his mom
and you don't feel anything for him it
just is not
working and you also sit there and
wonder at this point michael
is getting to know jimmy baxter pretty
well and how he operates how does he
think that
doing all this for jimmy that jimmy's
just not going to kill him at the end of
it like come on
obviously he would so you almost want
michael to make some kind of choice that
maybe he'll get his back on his side and
remember for him that
is something that will take jimmy down
and get out that way
somehow to expose jimmy getting behind
bars there's gotta be something here
something interesting they could have
put in instead of him just
kind of surviving like i said another
day in jimmy's grips and talk about eye
roll city here when
at the end of the episode supposed to
get this big oh my god moment when
frannie sees fia with adam poor franny
and her underage love story
now she can connect the dots that the
reason adam's not going to nyu is
actually for fia
who cares but as i'm being really hard
on this episode i'm trying to think of
stuff i liked and like i said
to be fair i think the acting was great
all around i think this was inevitable
though that the show was gonna actually
drop in quality because it's so
stretched out it's so unnecessary for
these episodes like this to be 57
minutes long
in a 10 episode series it's so much
content for a story that should just be
more tighter
and just brought in like i said to seven
or eight episodes so i just think this
is exact
formula to piss off fans that are
actually still into the show and i'm
just gonna be brutally honest
if i wasn't reviewing the show i would
have stopped watching it last episode
and then to wait two weeks come back to
this i really just
gotta give you guys props for sticking
with this and sticking with these
reviews please do because then it's
someone i could talk about these
episodes with because i'm gonna finish
it out but
man it is not easy so i'm giving this
episode
a 5.3 because it is just
really really dull and is resulting now
and not getting payoffs from everything
we watched earlier that i might have
liked in the season
and it's now just going down a really
boring path and you don't really feel
any excitement for the next episode
i mean if you do let me know let me know
if you really like this episode i'd love
to hear all your thoughts
let's get the discussion going please
make sure to subscribe so i miss one of
my reviews of your honor i also do other
tv shows like
juan division now and servants you don't
miss any of that i also do celebrity
interviews
and please follow me at steve barley
show on twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time